The fruit gum category is actually
an exception in confectionery is
actually the only category that I
can think of that has meat, so gelatine
is made from pork rinds and
we have eliminated this exception, yes
and because many people don't think
about it, even those who want it
are a problem  For example for Muslims,
yes, I don't know if it was always so
clear to them. We
also did this famous advertisement with the hitchup lady.
Many people thought we just wanted to
somehow annoy the AFD, complete
nonsense. We wanted to make the point clear
that people don't  If you
want to or can eat pork latin or
something else, at least not in candy, they
can have it in sausage
or something else that they are our
customers